We will look into this video
endomembrane system of eukaryotic cells.
The endometrial system.
At a very general level, the endometrial system includes
all the membranes that interact
in the cage.
Which membranes are involved?
I can start with myself
cell membrane.
All these membranes
have a double layer of phospholipids.
Sometimes the brain gives me a shortcut
and I call them bipillar strata,
but it is a double lipid layer.
If we focus here
and we increase that part,
we will see that this line is actually a double lipid layer.
It will look like this.
We have
hydrophilic heads pointing outwards
and hydrophobic tails that point inward.
The hydrophilic heads point outward,
hydrophobic tails point inward
and so the layer continues.
If we think about it from left to right
we have a double layer
of phospholipids.
This will be true for the cell membrane,
will be true
for the outer nuclear membrane here.
We've painted this membrane in the video about the endoplasmic network.
Here you see these two membranes.
You can say, "Okay, is this double layer?"
No, these are actually two double layers.
This membrane here has a dual phospholipid layer
and this membrane here
also has a dual phospholipid layer.
I will use another color.
What I begin to outline in the manager is
outer membrane from the nuclear shell.
It is connected to the membrane
of the endoplasmic network.
I begin to outline it too.
What I outline
in purple
is the inner membrane of the nuclear shell.
All of this is part of the endometrial system.
I have already started to talk about
the endoplasmic network.
We have explained some details about it in the video
for the endoplasmic grid and for the Golgi apparatus,
but it is also part of the endometrial system.
One-plane network can represent
50% or more of
phospholipid membranes in the cell.
We have already talked about what
occurs in the lumen of the endoplasmic reticulum.
This zone here -
We talked about what's going on there.
Synthesize proteins.
In fact, they can be synthesized there
and other molecules such as lipids.
They can then be transported to the smooth endoplasmic mesh,
but the place where they can leave the smooth endoplasmic grid,
we saw how they were tearing apart
in the video about the endoplasmic network.
We often call this area a transient endoplasmic grid.
This zone here
we can call the transient endoplasmic network.
Transient endoplasm
network is that part,
in which the proteins
are detached, wrapped in vesicles (secretory vesicles).
This is the transient endoplasmic network.
The secretory bubbles are these small compartments,
which are surrounded by a membrane
and can transport things like proteins.
I do not want to waste energy on the wind,
but all these lines that I paint,
although they are drawn as a single line,
are double layers of phospholipids.
The membrane may be different,
the dual phospholipid layer may be different
between the different parts of the membrane,
but all have the same common device,
have a dual phospholipid layer.
As a revision: these proteins
may exit the endoplasmic network through the transient endoplasmic network
and head to the Golgi apparatus.
We have already talked about how
proteins "ripen" in the Golgi apparatus.
When I say "ripen"
wants to say there are enzymes,
the enzymes of Goldie,
which can alter proteins in a variety of ways,
can label them, add
saccharides to them,
to become glycoproteins.
They can designate them as proteins that should be used
in the cell membrane
or outside the cell membrane,
or in other parts of the cell.
For example, this protein is broken off here
in a secretory bubble and headed to the Golgi apparatus,
the two membranes can be merged
and the protein gets into the Golgye apparatus.
There the protein can be modified there.
It can become a glycoprotein, for example,
who knows?
Then it may again tear off
and now this protein that is cut off in a secretory bubble
can be placed in the cell membrane.
The protein may be separated from the cell
or go to other parts of the cage.
All these membranes I talked about,
are not the only parts of the one-membrane system.
There are also things like vacuoles,
which are membrane organelles in the cell.
In plant cells the vacuole is used to store substances
or to maintain the cellular form and structure.
Vacuums can be quite large
and give
structure of the entire plant.
Lysosomes are present in animal cells.
Lysosomes are membrane structures,
in which are sent things that are for
recycling or demolition.
For example, something can be packed elsewhere.
I will use another color.
I drew this bubble too big.
But let's say that this has to be destroyed.
Therefore, this membrane merges with this membrane
and the contents of the bubble end up in the lysosome.
Lysozyme has a low pH,
thanks to that, the things that fall into the lysosomes are digested
and recycle
to their constituent parts.
All of this is part of the one-membrane system.
Once again, I repeat that people rarely realize
how complex the cells are
and how beautiful they can be.